mit einem traktor strahlen können in
star trek oder star wars fremde
raumschiffe festgehalten
manövrierunfähige schiffe abgeschleppt
oder unerwünschte objekte abgestoßen
werden und wer jetzt denkt das ist doch
alles science fiction krempe nichts da
einem forschungsteam aus bristol ist es
jetzt tatsächlich gelungen mit
schallwellen kugeln durch die luft
fliegen zu lassen und der hammer jeder
kann sich das gerät nachbauen wie das
genau funktioniert und ob das schon in
zukunft auch mit echten raumschiffen
klappt jetzt endlich zum science fiction
herzlich willkommen ja schon seit
jahrzehnten versuchen forschungsteams
weltweit das konzept des traktor strahls
aus star trek und star wars auch in der
realität umzusetzen 2015 war es erstmals
gelungen eine traktor strahl aus schall
zu erzeugung jetzt hat ein
forschungsteam aus brüssel einen traktor
strahl auf basis von schallwellen ganz
einfach selbst konstruiert dadurch
können objekte wie durch geisterhand
nicht nur einfach angehoben sondern auch
angezogen werden wie der traktor strahl
aus science fiction filmen die
wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaftler
nutzen dafür schrauben förmige wirbel
aus ultraschall diese wurden dem
experiment von spezial lautsprechern
abgefeuert so wurden den mini styropor
körnchen ständig winzige stöße von allen
seiten verpasst die virtuellen wirbel so
das forschungsteam macht es also möglich
die kugeln stabil in der schwebe zu
halten und noch mehr dazu einer der
beteiligten forscher asia x
er kann die objekte an die quelle der
schallwellen heranziehen es ist sehr
leicht partikel von der schallquelle
wegzuschieben oder sie einfach nur in
der schwebe zu halten aber sie
anzuziehen ist etwas ganz anderes und
das wirklich tolle ihr könnt euch selbst
einen solchen traktor strahl basteln
forschungsteam aus brüssel hat das gerät
so vereinfacht das ist jetzt mit
einfachen bauteilen aus dem 3d drucker
und dem internet gebaut werden kann am
ende sieht das gerät dann aus wie eine
überdimensionierte taschenlampe in einem
video beschreiben die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
wie man das gerät zusammenbauen kann am
ende lassen sich damit weniger
der kleine objekte anheben und anziehen
bei größeren objekten sei dass mit
diesem konzept bislang nicht möglich
gewesen kugel mit einem größeren
durchmesser bekamen durch die schall
wirbel einen drall und wurden aus dem
fokus des traktor strahls gefeuert
offenbar beschränkte die schallwellen
länge die größe des traktor strahlt so
das fazit des forschungsteams in einem
weiteren experiment veränderten sie alle
paar millisekunden die drehrichtung der
schall band so wurden sogar bis zu 1,6
zentimeter große styropor körnchen
stabil in der schwebe gehalten und das
ist echt ziemlich riesig
nach berechnungen der
wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaftler
sollten sich objekte mit einer dichte
bis zu 1,25 gramm pro kubikzentimeter
annehmen lassen heißt also im klartext
auch eine taufliege ließe sich per
traktor strahl einfangen
diese konzepte könnten demnächst auch in
der medizin anwendung finden
beispielsweise und medikamente innerhalb
des menschlichen körpers zu
transportieren in ferner zukunft könnte
man dann gegebenfalls auch ganze
menschen schweben lassen
bisher dachte man dass dies nur mit sehr
extremen schallwellen möglich sei doch
da wäre die verletzungsgefahr für uns
menschen eventuell viel zu hoch und
jetzt zurück zum weltraum in diesem
bereich würde das konzept des traktors
realistisch gesehen große probleme mit
sich bringen denn schall kann sich im
vakuum also im weltraum nicht ausbreiten
also müssen andere wellen quellen
verwendet werden
und auch hier dürfte den forschungsteams
dran doch mit laserstrahlen lassen sich
bisher damit nur objekte bewegen die
deutlich weniger als einen millimeter
messen wenn er als erstes neues zu
diesem thema und auch zu allen anderen
themen und erfahren wollt dann meldet
euch hierbei whatsapp an dann erfahrt
ihr vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der
redaktion von klicks um mitmachen und
themen vorschlagen oder fragen zu videos
stellen der direkte draht zu mir einfach
hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht
das abo mit der genau glocke vergessen
und hier geht es weiter mit dafür
draufklicken star wars todesstern laser
gebaut ansonsten
dann bleibt dran